hi this is presh tal Walker for mine
Pascal once considered the following
coin flipping game every time a coin
showed heads one point would be given to
firma and every time it show tails one
point would be given to Pascal the
object of the game was to get to ten
points and that person won a prize of
100 francs as they were playing the
score got to eight points to seven with
formal leading and they unfortunately
had to stop the game and couldn't
resumed it in the foreseeable future
they agreed that they would split up the
prize fairly according to the
probability that each could win the game
the problem to you is how did they split
up the prize if you take in probability
this problem might seem easy to you but
you have to remember this problem came
up in the mid 1600s actually between
firma and pascal and correspondence
before the theory of probability was
actually fleshed out in detail their
correspondence actually led to some
fundamental concepts being developed in
probability theory so give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
Vermont came up with a very ingenious
solution he imagined that when the score
was 8 points to 7 in his favor the game
would end for sure in for coin flips now
the game might end earlier in two flips
or three flips but for sure we can
imagine if we flip the coin four times
we know that the game would end for sure
so for ma said why don't we consider all
16 equally likely sequences of four coin
flips and see the number of cases in
which he would win and the number of
cases in which Pascal would win now if
there were three or more tails that
would be a victory for Pascal there are
five cases for that the remaining eleven
cases would be victories for firma so
for ma de deuce that there's an 11 out
of 16 or 68.75 percent chance that he
would win the game so he should be
awarded 68.75 percent of the prize now
this solution is correct but since it
doesn't always make sense for people
that you extend the flips out beyond the
game ending
I'm going to show you another way that
you could solve this problem so imagine
the game is tied
9 points to 9 what's the probability
that each player is going to win the
game the answer is each person has a 50%
chance of winning because the coin is
equally likely to show up heads or tails
and this is going to be true whenever
the score is tied
8 8 7 7 and so on anytime the score is
tied
there's an equal chance that either
player is going to score a point and
therefore either player has a 50% chance
of winning so now let's consider another
situation
what if Verma is leading the game 9
points to 8 what is his probability of
winning the game well there's a 50%
chance he might flip ahead from flip
heads at this point and he'll win the
game at 10 points to 8 so for the 50%
chance contingency the coin shows heads
there's a hundred percent chance that he
would win there's a 50% chance the coin
would also show tails in which case the
score would go to 9 to 9 and we just
argued that would be a 50% win share for
4 ma so we can calculate the wind share
at 9 to 8 by combining the contingencies
that could result if we average out the
two contingencies and the probability of
winning in each of those there is a 75%
chance that Verma wins the game with the
score of 9 to 8 by symmetry that would
mean there's a 25% chance that Pascal
would win the game
when formas leading 9 to 8 so we can
also say that when formas losing 8
points to 9 he has a 25% chance of
winning and we can also calculate that
by averaging out the contingencies so
let's imagine now the game is 9 points
to 7 well if Verma gets a heads then
that means he's going to win outright if
he gets a tails the score is going to go
to 9 to 8 and we just argued that's a
75% win share for him so we can average
out these two possibilities and
calculate that his wind share at 97 will
be 87 point 5 percent finally we can get
to the problem we wanted to solve which
is
if the game is eight points to seven
with four mile leading well if the coin
shows heads that's going to get to a
score of nine to seven which we just
calculated with an eighty seven point
five percent wind share and if the coin
shows the tails which has happens with
50 percent chance then the score goes to
eight eight or 4 mods a 50 percent wind
share so averaging these two
contingencies we see that for Moz wind
share at eight to seven is sixty eight
point seven five percent which is the
same conclusion that Verma found out by
imagining flipping the coin four times
and calculating the number of sequences
in which he would win so both methods
are valid way of solving this problem
and whichever method makes sense to you
is fine to use did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch
around my blog mind your decisions which
you can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
app brushed I Walker and if you like
this video please check out my books
there are links in the video description